the whole praise is due to Allah
Beyond gracious Beyond merciful
the one whom guides and for who he
guides
they cannot be misguided
and for who he misguides they cannot be
guided to the truth
I testify that Allah
is the only
only not even thing nothing that can be
worshiped
because no word can Encompass what he is
and I testify by Allah
but Prophet Muhammad
is the final Prophet the Seal of the
prophets the most perfect man to have
ever walked this Earth
and the greatest example for all of us
are Mercy sent to mankind
I ask of you all to make a Dua for me
that I may be able to communicate with
you in the most coherent manner possible
um this is actually my first major
lecture
um and I'm actually quite nervous
so if you could please make a door for
me I would really appreciate that and
that Allah May accept my Deeds today
that I may be weighed on
the good scale on the day of judgment
and then it may be expiation from my
sins I mean
my name is
prior to getting into this uh
interesting lecture I'd like to tell you
a little bit about myself and why I'm
standing up here today
um
I um have been studying this very
subject here for the past seven years of
my academic career I did my bachelor's
in Western philosophy I did my Master's
in Islamic philosophy
and um
well I decided to change a career paths
after that so now I'm doing my PhD in
Sharia because my mother inquired how I
was going to get a job with Philosophy
degree
and I used to tell her that I can think
long deep thoughts about unemployment
but
um so I decided to change my my degree
to Sharia
and she told me oh that's so good you
know now you can do law and other such
things and my PhD thesis is on Isis
so
um she wasn't quite happy about that
because you know now it seems as though
I might be in danger in the future uh
but at least my life has gotten a little
bit more exciting
um
let's see I am also uh from the United
States however my family is originally
from Spain hence my title alandrusi so
in case any of you have any confusion
about that so I think that's enough
about me I don't want to make this whole
lecture about myself so uh let's
actually get right into it if you could
please
foreign okay
so why are we here why are we discussing
atheism today uh many of you have uh
signed up for this course to learn about
atheism to understand atheism
um at least I hope so unless you're here
just because you're bored I mean you
know it's another thing you can do but
why are we here to discuss atheism
well atheism is actually a rising
problem globally
um a recent report and Gallup poll
International 2012 and this is the most
recent that they currently have actually
we haven't gotten anything more recent
than that showed that there was a rise
of atheism globally at three percent and
a steady decline of religiosity at nine
percent okay some of the countries
mentioned show the following numbers of
convince atheism within their
populations if you could please click
the uh keep going Saudi Arabia Palestine
Pakistan and Malaysia so I picked some
Muslim countries here to to uh you know
pique your interest a little bit so
let's see what about Saudi Arabia five
percent convinced atheists please uh
wait for me to uh who thinks uh what
about Palestine who here can answer me
how many atheists convinced atheists are
in Palestine I'm not talking about
Israel I'm talking about Gaza in the
West Bank
17 atheist mashallah
okay wow
anybody anything else
ten percent a little bit High
we'll say about four percent okay how
about Pakistan mostly majority probably
what 99 percent
you try that one how many
hmm you guys are really pessimistic it's
like you're shooting really high can you
go
two percent
okay how about Malaysia
one percent
right zero
zero percent convinced atheist in
Malaysia apparently we're going to get
to that in a second but before we do
before I discuss these numbers and what
they actually mean
okay for the given populations that I've
just listed I want to mention how many
registered is irreligious
can you please click
nineteen percent for Saudi Arabia claim
that they are not religious Muslims
okay 29 of Palestine
29 that's almost a third of the whole
population
claims that they are not religious at
all meaning they just believe in God
okay they don't practice
eight percent in Pakistan and 13
Malaysia
13.
all right now if we combine these
numbers obviously it's a little bit
higher now it's more significant okay
and there's actually a correlation
between these numbers you may think that
being non-religious
means that it has no connection to
atheism but actually that there's that's
quite the opposite is true if we can go
on please
and one of the reasons I I speculate
about the zero percent in Malaysia is
because of forms like this uh I'm a
member of this group don't don't
question my akita now okay because I'm
not an atheist all right I come here to
practice and what I mean by practice is
I like to use people's punching bags for
my arguments and I like to test my
arguments out on atheists so I go online
sometimes and
you know poke at them so
um this forum is called warang atheist I
hope I pronounced that right I'm not
Malaysian I'm sorry
um and it has
3537 members most of them claim to be
murtadine
okay so you have over 3
if you count give her a few maybe the
theists in there that are arguing okay
over 3 000 apostates
on this forum alone
all right so that zero percent seems a
little bit uh
doesn't make much sense does it and this
is actually my Facebook page so I'm
seeing some of the brothers here
probably on their phones trying to add
me so okay you can save it for later uh
sisters please don't do that uh not
saying that you are but uh my my future
wife might kill me so please don't do
that okay so if we can yeah future I'm
still keeping it that way so next okay
please
one more all right so let's go to uh
some more information that I found
rather shocking rather startling if you
click again atheism by religious
affiliation actually these same
researchers
they did surveys on people who claim to
be of certain religious groups
interesting right on a global scale so
let's look at those religious groups if
we could among the major religious
affiliations surveyed on a global scale
the following percentages have either
declared themselves convinced atheists
that'll be the first number you see
non-religious
and or undecided meaning they don't know
if they're atheist or not yet
okay
can we go to the uh next Christian
Jewish Hindu and Muslim okay so let's
see about Christians declared atheists
convinced one percent globally not bad
Jewish two percent not surprised
Hindu three percent Muslim
three percent
of the global population of Muslims
is considered to be convinced atheists
people who say that they're Muslim but
yet they're actually atheists okay these
are people who have yet to apostate
maybe or maybe they have apostated and
they just they still declare the title
so this is non-religiosity among the
Christians is 16 Jewish 54 once again
not surprised
the Hindu 12 Muslim 20.
20 percent
non-religious globally so now you have
23 percent
basically on the edge of their faith or
completely outside
okay this is only in 2012 the numbers
have risen since then we don't know the
exact percentages but I think Saudi
Arabia now as I said it was five percent
last time but I think it Rose to six or
seven
in the past few years that's almost 10
of the population that has now convinced
atheists out of a majority Muslim
population in the most conservative
parts of the Middle East and the Muslim
World in general and the undecided four
percent for Christian Jewish six percent
Hindu three and Muslim three so in terms
of the potential atheist you have 23
percent in the Muslim world
so almost a third of the global Muslim
population is either not religious
or they're becoming atheists
does that sound uh
a little shocking
how many Muslims are in the world
a little higher than that
it's about 1.8 something though
so what's 20 percent
of that population
can you imagine
you can do the math by yourself I'm not
going to do it on my head because I'll
have a headache but
um but imagine that's a very significant
number okay
please continue
all right let's see Islamic scholars are
only now starting to address this I just
read this report recently the world
Bulletin
click again please
Egyptians Egypt's Muslim Christian
authorities unite against atheism
and I'm going to read you this little
story here
Christian churches in Egypt say there
are joining forces with Egypt okay so
the Christians are the ones who approach
the Muslims
all right
the church in Alaska are drafting a
constructive mechanism to address
atheism
this statement came following a two-day
conference organized jointly between us
and the church aimed at forging a
scholarly response to atheism
which they said has been spreading
increasingly in Egypt over the past
three years
okay so they're actually quite alarmed
by this phenomenon they think there's
something very problematic about this
especially among the youth
all right now you're probably wondering
that if the scholars are finally
deciding to construct the response to
atheists why am I standing here
because I'm not a scholar right
well before we go to the next slide I'd
like to explain that
the scholarly tradition the ulama
while they are still advanced in Arabic
and in terms of the traditional studies
okay
um there has been a sharp decline
in terms of how they address outside
religions to be honest with you they are
still utilizing arguments from several
centuries ago
the problem is that atheists have
changed their beliefs in the past
hundred years and many people don't know
that unless of course you study at the
philosophy Department
which is unfortunate because it should
be common knowledge
um
so the arguments that
a lot of the Muslims and the scholars
are using are actually not effective
for this new brand of atheism and we're
going to discuss what that type of
atheism is it's contemporary form of
atheism as it is today
please continue
so what does this have to do with me
you're probably wondering to yourself if
you're alarmed At All by these
percentages if you're alarmed At All by
the fact that Muslims have
begun to stray away from their religion
if you're alarmed at all that atheism is
actually the fastest growing ideology on
the planet it's not Islam by the way
people think it's Islam that's not true
atheism is growing at a 20 faster rate
okay
so what does that to do with me well
first off how about we address the Quran
because whenever we want to ask a
question about our lives we should
address the Quran
correct okay so what does the Quran say
who could say who could say anything
better than someone who summons to Allah
and acts rightly and says I am one of
the Muslims so this is a this is
basically the Quran or Allah is
basically saying that anyone who does
dawa okay they're the successful ones
this is somebody who is at a very high
rank
okay continue please
Quran also says let there be a community
among you who call to the good and
enjoying the right and forbid the wrong
they are the ones who have success they
are the ones who have success so right
now the Quran is telling you let's do
that one in general in general is to
receive reward okay to to or to correct
or wrong is to receive a reward okay we
have uh the Hadith literature
also boxes
and the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam said to Ali but Allah if a
single person is Guided by Allah through
you it will be better for you than a
whole lot of red camels Now red camels
were also very valued asset back then
okay so what it means is if you want to
to translate it into contemporary
terminology a lot of red Ferraris or a
lot of you know diamonds or tons of gold
I think anything that you would consider
to be most valuable to you so bringing
one person to Islam is more valuable for
you in the afterlife than than any sort
of material gain
and the Quran also provides sort of the
the example that should be uh the
example for you and uh to perform this
deed so you have an excellent model the
messenger of Allah
for all who put their hope and Allah on
the last day and remember Allah much
continue please
say and this is uh Allah speaking to
Muhammad
say this is my way I call to Allah with
inner side or basira okay
I and all who follow me glory be to
Allah I am not one of the idolaters not
one of the disbelievers okay
continue
the prophet salallahu said he was asked
something he knows and conceals it will
have a bridle of fire put on on him on
the day of Resurrection so actually the
information I'm giving you today
you should probably spread that around
because it'll be very bad not to
um please continue there's actually a
weaker Hadith and we use weak Hadith of
course to support we don't always use
them for direct evidence but when
they're in you know they supplement
so this one is actually even more
interesting the messenger of Allah said
whoever conceals knowledge which Allah
has made beneficial for Mankind's
Affairs of religion so it's very
specific there if you notice okay
Allah will Bridle him with the Reigns of
fire in the day of Resurrection please
continue
the Quran continues so do not obey the
disbelievers but use this Quran to
battle against them with all your might
Jihad
but the sword of the Quran
the Hadith states that I heard the
messenger of Allah
saying he who amongst you sees something
abominable should modify with the help
of his hand many people know this Hadith
already if he is not strong enough to do
so then with his tongue and if he is
still not strong enough to do so then at
least to abhor in one's heart and that's
the weakest of Iman
the weaker uh variation of the sort of
striving Jihad with your hands your
tongues and your wealth okay
continue and this is what I really want
to discuss actually commenting on the
Ayah that we just revealed earlier okay
said Jihad with decisive proof and the
tongue takes precedence over Jihad with
The Sword and the spear takes precedence
meaning that it's first
beyond all things today we talk a lot
about fighting the kufaula
but in fact the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam as an example to us said that
the Precedence is with your your tongue
first with arguments argumentation
everyone has a succession of Angels in
front of him and behind him guarding by
Allah's command Allah never changes the
person's State until they change what is
in themselves when Allah desires evil
for people there is no averting it they
have no protector apart from him now
before you go on uh I would like to
explain why I
brought this uh brought this Ayah up
and a lot of people often
um misconstrue
and I'm saying this very deliberately
misconstrued this Ayah
to mean as a personal endeavor change
myself
if I change myself
then my condition will change however
this is not the case
it can be read in that way however the
traditional opinion
is that it's a collective Duty
it's not talking about you personally
okay it's not talking about how you
change yourself
and then your condition will change it's
talking about the community in general
and we have evidence for this from Iman
courtabi
Andalusian scholar okay
he is probably one of my ancestors I
don't know
so uh he's commenting on the side here
Allah most high informs Us in this verse
that he will not change a people until
change occurs in them whether from
themselves or those in charge of them or
those put over them for a reason however
the verse does not mean that punishment
will be sent by Allah for someone who
commits a sin rather punishment and
affliction may be sent down due to the
sins of others based on what the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam replied to
when asked by his companions are we
going to be destroyed even when we have
righteous people among us
where he said yes when filth and
Corruption becomes prevalent and Allah
Knows Best
this is a community injunction
when it means that you must change the
condition of yourself before the before
Allah does so he's talking about not
just yourself he's talking about also
your community for instance is not just
a personal matter
if you extend it out to your neighbors
Imam Malik for instance stated that
there is no Sharia without us when there
is no tussa wolf without what Sharia
the two are interconnected it's
impossible to separate them
so Jihad
okay is a collective Duty it's an
obligation upon all of us whether by the
Tongue whether by the sword or whether
by our wealth
and it is in uh incumbent upon us
especially when it's within our own
community so this has a lot to do with
us in the sense that we have a rise of
anti-intellectualism we have a rise of
atheism we have a rise of people who are
becoming apostates in our faith so it is
an obligation upon all of us to do
intellectual Jihad not just for the sake
of our own Souls but for the sake of our
community around us
this is not an option
this is absolutely not an option at all
if we consider that if somebody invades
our territory our land our homes kicks
down our door and tries to kill our
family we consider an obligation to
fight back correct in the same way
our faith
our Prophet saws honor
is more important to us than our lives
so Our obligation to defend our religion
is much higher than our own lives
okay that's why he said that Jihad with
the tongue meaning the intellect takes
precedence precedence over that of the
sword
okay so what's there to learn oh there's
gonna be a lot actually
okay well what is atheism and the types
of atheism that's going to be one
continue
sort of It's a small uh you know table
of contents the five most common atheist
beliefs I'm going to give you all the
five most common ones continue arguments
used by atheists
why is atheism becoming more popular
responding to atheist beliefs and
arguments
common objections to Islam by atheists
and disbelievers in general
atheist psychology and how to debate
an introduction to logical fallacies and
uh don't don't go to the next page yet
basically we're going to cover
um all the way to this point right here
responding to atheist beliefs and
arguments in this day
okay the next day we will go on to
Common objections atheist psychology
introduction to logical fallacies
tomorrow I'm basically going to teach
you how to argue
and you're probably asking me well how
can I do that what credentials well
part of my education in philosophy was
that
they teach you how to argue so
um I actually had probably I don't know
five or six classes on just logical
fallacies alone
um and a logical fallacies essentially
just an argument that is invalid or a
statement that's an invalid so it's
things that you commonly that you
actually should not say in an argument
I'm going to teach you how to avoid
those things and how to point them out
so that when you actually get in
discussion with somebody
and you know you can see whether what
they're saying
is valid and whether it's worth
addressing and you can point out say
look you know I think you're saying
something wrong here so then you don't
have to get diverted from what you're
from your message okay because I'm
actually a lot of people it will crumble
that up and throw it away so a lot of
people
um usually get diverted by rhetoric you
know a lot of people they know how to
talk in this day and age but if you
actually examine the way that people
talk you'll notice that there's no
substance to most of it
so what is atheism and this is probably
going to be the most important thing
that we need to learn right now because
definitions matter before we talk about
a subject we need to know what it is
obviously so Atheism in the dictionary
today the Oxford dictionary says states
that the disbelief or lack of belief in
God are Gods now before we go on
I'd like to ask is anybody here
understand this definition
does anybody know the distinctions
or what were those definitions trying to
say
because
prior to about 10 years the recent
decade
this definition used to be only one of
these two and there was no ore there was
only one
it was the disbelief in God meaning the
belief that God does not exist
so now it's recently changed by
including lack of belief in God or gods
and that's actually a very important
distinction which we're going to get
into because that actually defines the
majority of atheists in the world today
most atheists will not say they believe
God does not exist
most I'm talking about 99 percent
will say that they simply lack a belief
in God isn't that agnostic uh we will
get to the question answers we'll get to
the to that as well
um but you are correct to some degree
except that atheists have actually
combined
the concept of agnosticism with atheism
now and I'll show you how they did that
so the origins of the late 16th century
from the French atheism from the Greek
atheists from the negative a which means
without and Theos which is God
okay continue please historical fun
facts one more
the word atheism was commonly used by
certain religious communities against
other religious communities
the first time that it was actually used
in this way was with the Christians
when the Christians first came about in
the Roman Empire the Romans called them
atheists because they did not believe in
the pagan gods they said you don't
believe in our Gods you're atheists
and the Christians responded said no
you're an atheist because you don't
believe in the true God so they were
calling each other atheists during the
Crusades the Muslims and the Christians
were calling each other atheists
believe it or not that's very strange
right because they did not believe each
other they both said
we both basically we said you don't
believe in Allah who is the true God so
you're atheist you don't believe in God
and the Christmas responders that you
don't believe in
Jesus as a God so therefore you're an
atheist so it was actually it was a a
much more specific meaning okay and
nowadays it's more broadly means just in
general somebody who doesn't believe in
any gods and so the concept of God
itself has become equalized in the term
atheist
okay so what types of atheism are there
okay one more there's practical atheism
which is about Behavior
can you stop please and
practical atheism is simply about how
you act as a person okay you're you're
attitude
towards the existence of God so we have
something under practical atheism called
apotheism
does anybody know the word apathetic
apathetic
pathetic yeah that's it's a good that's
a good one yeah so
apathetic apathetic means you don't you
have no concern for it you don't care
so when I'm apathetic like say about
politics I'm apathetic about politics I
just don't care about politics I do care
about politics I'm using an example but
um so apathyism
is doesn't care if God exists at all so
it's not like you ask him does God exist
he's just like I it doesn't really
matter to me you know I'm going to live
my life like this anyway so
you know
um then there's non-religious
one more doesn't care about what God
desires now there's actually a
distinction between these one just
doesn't care if God exists the other one
acknowledges God exists but doesn't care
that he has commands or that he has a
will he just doesn't you know he could
be a deist a deist is somebody who
believes in God but a God that doesn't
interfere with the world but generally a
non-religious person is somebody who who
acknowledges there's a God but acts like
an atheist
so somebody who may be for instance a
Muslim but drinks fornicates does
everything an atheist would do and acts
like it's not a big deal
so you know sisters in Islam
um I apologize okay uh I had to throw
that in there
um so then we have theoretical atheism
which is about ideas and this is the one
that we're really going to be discussing
the most here uh one more please
so there are two types of Atheism in the
theoretical level there's strong or
positive atheism which is
the belief that God does not exist
the belief that God does not exist so
they have a firm belief
that God does not exist
okay
then there's weak or negative atheism
that's the one that lacks a belief in
God they say I don't know
okay they say I don't have enough
evidence I don't have enough reason to
believe that there's a God I simply lack
the belief that's it so don't blame me
for anybody that's you know so it's sort
of it's almost like a defense mechanism
and they actually use it that way as
well we'll get into that more later
so these are the this is actually a very
general
um
categorization because there's actually
quite a few more atheists but the
popular ones that you're going to be
approached by or that you're going to
approach in your life are going to be
from this area right here the weak
atheist section and they typically have
very common beliefs whereas the strong
atheist I've dealt with them in
philosophy circles usually professors of
philosophy and things like this they
usually have very strange ideas that
you're typically not going to encounter
and I'll give you one example
I had one professor in college in my
bachelor's when I was doing my
bachelor's and we would have interesting
discussions
and it and I wasn't concerned so much
that he was an atheist more
I was more concerned about the fact that
he believed something else which I
I was constantly trying to convince him
otherwise
because I just felt it was very absurd
so
his belief was that he didn't know if
the real of the world was real
and um
well when you talk to somebody like that
you really can't get any farther because
if they don't believe the world is real
then
huh
uh no actually he was uh he was a
anglo-american former Christian
um but he believed the world wasn't real
and I don't mean that he had like a
platonist idea like he thought there was
Illusions or anything no he believed he
honestly did not know
whether he was living
in the real world
um so he kind of liked the movie The
Matrix a lot so he was always trying to
debate whether what was actually going
on was actually going on
so he was preoccupied with himself quite
a bit and so his atheisms with least of
my concerns
um and of course by doing that he also
negated his own existence he didn't know
if he actually existed
and you may think that's absurd but
there's actually philosophers that are
like that
and in the philosophy Department we have
a strange phenomenon and this may
discourage you from studying philosophy
we have a strange phenomenon where we
call uh Nietzsche burnout Niche burnout
is a German existentialist philosopher
he was responsible for the nihilist
movement which means that there was no
values in life basically our values were
determined subjectively by human beings
so basically our values what we consider
to be moral or good or bad is determined
solely by humans okay based on what we
just simply desire what we consider to
be the normal good whatever it's it's
all subjective in that sense well when
somebody becomes a ni list and they
start to lose their ground and reality
meaning they've jumped into philosophy
so much that they sort of drowned
themselves in these skepticism
uh they end up committing suicide
and I've known a few colleagues and a
few students in My Philosophy Department
who have unfortunately succumbed to that
because they question themselves too
much to the point where they kill
themselves
so um
something else I'd like to mention was
that uh theoretical atheism has a direct
causation on the Practical atheism okay
so any beliefs that you hear from the
theoretical side will automatically
influence the behavior of the society
that they're in and we'll get to that
point I mean as well so what are the
common beliefs of atheists
well before we get into that let's have
some story time okay
so I brought up a book
that uh you guys are familiar with story
time
you've had story time before
I remember story time I love story time
I missed it a lot you know I'm 30 now
and it's like you know I wish I could go
back to that time so I've decided to uh
to bring you all back to this time so I
brought a book here
and um I thought I'd tell you a story
it's a fairy tale
about atheism
okay and this is what atheists tell
themselves but it's more of like a
childish fashion so maybe you'll get a
kick out of it I don't know so I'm gonna
sit here
like the good teacher that I am and you
can all just listen okay all right
it's good
all right once upon a time
I'm serious
paper there once upon a time there was a
terrible monster that lived in the sky
but you didn't anybody knows it's
referring to yet okay we'll keep going
no one had ever seen it because it lived
a long way away
and because it was invisible
but everyone knew it was there because a
long time ago it had shown itself to
some very clever men
these very clever men explained how the
monster had one head three bodies and a
thousand eyes
which with which it could see into
people's Souls they told terrible Tales
of what the Monster would do if they got
angry but also of how kind it was that
people would only worship it without
thought or a question
they explained how the monster had given
them a powerful magic which if used
rightly would protect the world from
Evil sometimes the monster would get
angry and when it did the clever man
would offer its sacrifices
dragging people into Market squares
where they would burn them alive just to
show the monster how much they loved it
the people listened to the very clever
men and believed them but they still
yearn to be free of the monster
and then one day a few brave men who had
only ever pretended to believe in a
monster unearth the chest of strange
metal
the chest had been hidden by an earlier
wiser Freer people who had lived in the
land before the monster came and had
known a better way of life
ever so slowly the men began to work the
metal which they called reason
using it to forge a new weapon which
they called science
and they used science to attack the
monster
and the very clever men
they had to be very careful though at
first because if anyone was caught using
science they would be dragged into
Market squares whether we burned alive
and indeed this was how many men lost
their lives
but these were brave men not to be
fooled by fables or threats
they're banned multiplied and their
weapons grew in number and power until
one day a brilliant reclusive Rebel
invented a super weapon which he called
evolution
which could punch clean to the monster's
armored scales after that the attacks
increased in frequency and ferocity
until one day the rebels were able to
show the people what they had long known
themselves
the monster had never actually existed
it was just a tale told by the very
clever men to keep themselves and riches
in power
slowly the truth spread and although
some very clever men still cling to
riches in power and some very stupid
Ones Still Believe them gradually
wonderfully the world is being set free
the end
was that a good story
lovely story
okay
well as juvenile as it may seem this is
actually what many atheists believe
so I'm going to put my story chair back
okay so we're going to get into the
actual academic discussion of those
atheist beliefs
okay and I gave you that story because
not just to entertain you but I actually
wanted you to to understand what they
believe
and then once you see what these beliefs
are in their academic fashion you'll
start to translate it into that myth
so the first
of the Contemporary atheist is something
called anti-theism
okay it's called anti-theism theism is
the belief in God and T is what
against
okay the belief that theism and religion
in general need to be opposed and
eradicated because they are
intellectually unjustifiable and harmful
to mankind
next please one such individual by the
name of Sam Harris from the United
States the author of the end of Faith
he's the First new atheist author he
said this if I could wave a magic wand
and get rid of either rape or religion I
would not hesitate to get rid of
religion
I think more people are dying as a
result of our religious myths than as a
result of any other ideology
so this man says that he would rather
get rid of religion than rape
that's I don't know what that's shocking
to
that I think that's quite disgusting and
I'm sorry to be so direct
um another uh famous author by the name
of Christopher Hitchens Lake Christians
he recently passed away a few years ago
I'm not an even an atheist so much as
I'm an anti-theist I'd only maintain
that all religions are versions of the
same untruth but I hope that the
influence of churches and the effect of
religious belief is positively harmful
okay so this is their first major belief
thanks
the next one is evidentialism
this is a philosophical term
evidentialism I'll explain it to you
more the belief that any or all
positions require evidence to be
accepted
in other words a person is Justified in
believing not believing or withholding
belief based on whether or not they have
sufficient evidence at the given time a
proposition is made
once this is used in opposition to the
concept often this is used in opposition
to constant of Faith or belief without
evidence okay so the new atheist such as
this man Richard Dawkins giving a speech
in 1992 he said faith is the great
cop-out the great excuse to evade the
need to think and devaluate evidence
faith is belief in spite of even perhaps
because of the lack of evidence
so they base The Atheist claim that they
based all of their beliefs on evidence
and they believe and they base their
rejection
of beliefs based on evidence or lack
thereof excuse me
number three scientism
we will get into this term more actually
in the near future
this is actually a word many atheists
will deny this term however it's been
around since the 1800s
maybe even earlier than that
the belief that the methods of natural
science or the categories and things
recognized in Natural Science form the
only proper elements that any
philosophical or other inquiry in other
words science is the only way to know
anything
the new atheist or the majority of
atheists in the world today actually
believe this
and Victor stenger who has just recently
died as well uh he uh wrote in the new
atheism defending Richard Dawkins Sam
Harris Christopher visions and all the
other atheist uh leaders who have
written a lot of literature on the
subject uh can you go back sorry
he said
and they recommended this book so they
firmly believe him in this respect the
new atheist firmly insists that the
personal abrahamic or Islamic perception
of God is a scientific hypothesis that
can be tested by the standard methods of
science so they honestly believe
that the concept of God can be tested
using scientific inquiry
okay next number four humanism look
whatever
okay humanism
the belief that human beings should be
the center of Mankind's concerns that we
are the only source of Ethics
legislation and values in this world and
that God or gods are unnecessary in
determining our destiny the ancient
Greek philosopher epicurus
uh would set the stage for this line of
thinking
oh actually that's an error
I want to point out I make errors
sometimes it's not epicurus his name is
euthyphro okay so I will edit that later
for your convenience I apologize
he said if God is all-powerful then why
can he not stop evil and if he is all
good then why does he refuse
that's a question that we will be
getting into actually later as well it's
called the the argument
for evil or theodicy issue that brother
Rehan had mentioned earlier and AC
Grayling uh who wrote The God argument
in 2014 said the human good is for human
responsibility to discern and enact
without Reliance upon or invocation of
any of any of the major religions which
claim a transcendental Authority and
posthumous Rewards or punishments so he
is basically claiming that human beings
are the only uh rulers of their fate and
destiny okay and that we do not need a
God to determine that next
number five
progressionism
this is another philosophical term this
is one that many atheists actually don't
even know they have
um but I've encountered many of these uh
many arguments from your position
and the belief that humanity is
gradually advancing in science
technology ethics and legislation due to
the absence of religion this belief
became popularized around the time of
the Enlightenment okay and Christopher
Hitchens once again stated one must
state of plainly religion comes from the
period of human prehistory where nobody
had the smallest idea of what was going
on
okay so basically he's saying that
religion came purely from ignorance in
the past when people didn't have science
it comes from the balding up
wow you're from faster than me so he
comes from the balding and fearful
infancy of our species and it is a
baby-ish attempt to meet our incapable
demand for knowledge all attempts to
reconcile Faith with science and reason
are consigned to failure and ridicule
for precisely these reasons okay next
so now that we understand the primary
atheist beliefs let's get into their
main arguments how much time do we have
still good
almost okay 30 minutes left
so the first argument uh by the way I've
cataloged these myself
um this is not from a book this is from
my own personal experience and study
over the years I've debated with many
atheists
um
I have discussed with many atheist
philosophers Etc so these are my own
um categorizations okay this is what I
have found to be the majority of eight
arguments throughout the years the
argument for antitheism so you see P1
here it means premise one
okay so when you see in philosophy we
like to write our arguments like this so
we put the first premise there'll be P1
P2 and the conclusion is C at the end so
just in case you need to know
you want any belief that
most views about the natural world and
ethics should be opposed anybody agree
with that
yeah okay next
theistic religions teach false views
about the natural world and ethics
okay number three our conclusion sorry
therefore theistic religion should be
opposed that's the argument
now this is a syllogism and syllogism is
just a very concise format for which the
argument goes now in actuality there is
much more to this than meets the eye
okay for instance in premise 2. all
right everyone agrees with premise one
but not everyone agrees a premise too
now the new atheists will make Arguments
for premise too okay so there's more
information that goes under there all
right so they'll say well we have
historical evidence that shows that
religions cause more Wars or we have a
lot of evidence to show that there's
more extremists in religious societies
than non-religious societies think so
they'll do this to back that up okay but
you can oppose this and say no that's
wrong okay but the actual argument
itself is valid and I'm going to teach
you this also for those of you who don't
know uh any basic logic or have taken a
basic logic course but there's a
difference between a valid argument
and a sound argument
okay a valid argument means that it's
logically consistent that means that it
it's coherent okay it's true by
definition
all right however a sound argument is
true in reality
so an argument can be valid but it
doesn't mean it's sound it can be false
okay and if an argument is invalid then
it's automatically false
all right
so this argument implies that such
beliefs are harmful to mankind an
empirical experience claim based on
observation okay and based on the belief
of anti-theism
primary atheist arguments number two
the argument for the irrationality of
theism and religion theism being the
belief in God
P1 any claim that lacks evidence is
unjustified anybody agree with this
I'm gonna try to change your mind by the
end of this course
okay P2 unjustified claims are
irrational
now is it ever agree with that one
the subjective okay we'll get into that
theism and religion lack evidence
okay therefore theism and religion are
irrational
implies that evidence is necessary for
every claim
the implication is there based on the
belief of evidentialism are you starting
to see connections
okay
next
the argument for the universality of
science
P1 evidence is necessary for any belief
to be justified and explained so this is
based on evidentialism the first premise
premise too science offers the only
reliable form of evidence and
explanation
theism and religion are beliefs
therefore only scientific evidence can
justify theism and religion
implies that evidence is necessary to
justify any belief basically from the
last argument implies science is
universal in determining justification
explanation for any belief and based on
the belief of what
scientism right
next
the argument for evil and human
Independence believe it or not
the argument for evil that we discussed
earlier
ties in
to what we're going to see is humanism
in a minute so we're going to see it
through this argument
it is claimed that God is all-powerful
and all good is this correct in Islam
Christianity and Judaism right
if God were all-powerful he could
prevent evil from happening
if God were all good he would not allow
evil to exist
a moral person cannot rely on or follow
a God that cannot prevent evil or does
not want to
evil exists
therefore God is either not all-powerful
or all good and thus mankind should be
what
apotheistic remember apathyism means
they should not care that you exist or
not
implies that the existence of evil
counsels out God's attributes and his
authority
implies that evil exists and there is no
good purpose for it at all
based on the belief of
humanism
and concludes that people should simply
not care about God's existence
okay next
number five
the argument for incompatibility between
science and religion or you could just
call this the argument from the argument
for incompatibility
for something to be compatible it must
be complementary
okay so that's very basic basically what
I'm trying to say there is that they
should not contradict each other they
should not
okay to reject one thing over another
means that something is not
complementary Society had to reject
religious Dogma for science to advance
therefore religion is incompatible with
science now before we go into this
section P3 is the contested issue
P3 is the contested issue
okay the first two premises most people
will agree to the third one is the issue
did people really have to reject
scientific Dogma I mean excuse me uh
that's also true but did they did they
really have to reject religious Dogma to
it to let science Advance that's
actually a common myth and we read in
that little nice little fairy tale
that's what most atheists believe is
that the reason that we have scientific
advancement today the reason we have all
the health care that we have all the
weapons and technology that we have is
because
people
unburdened themselves from the shackles
of religious Dogma
okay because we are secularists
with the church
that's what's claimed and during the
Enlightenment yes and the Renaissance
and things like this well actually it
started during the Renaissance fully
enveloped itself in the enlightenment
period and then when the state took over
they're claiming that
um and they do use the the history of
the church as evidence of this however
even that is contestable because in
actuality and I'm going to just explain
this more but since you brought it up in
actuality the Catholic church was a very
big facilitator of science
one of the largest
in fact it gave more funding to
Scientific to scientific inquiry and
technological production than most other
institutions did at the time now the
reason that we have some problems and
since we're already getting into the
topic I'll just sort of side track here
anybody heard of Galileo
okay you know what happened to him
huh he was a kill I don't remember
exactly remember I know he was killed
though but they say is because he wanted
to replace a scientific theory that the
church upheld
now the church upheld at the time the
poltamic system which means that this
the Earth was the center of the Galaxy
the center of the universe okay and that
the sun rotated around the earth and the
moon okay so anyways
um Galileo apparently came by and said
no you're wrong it's Copernicus
excuse me cabernetes theory that was
correct and that everything rotates
around the Sun so because of this the
church got scared and said no you're
wrong we're going to kill you because
you made blasphemy that's the simple
Story the actual story is much more
complex than that in fact many of the
early church leaders were already
moving in that direction
the problem was is that when Galileo was
trying to convince the pope you know the
pope at the time that his theory was
correct he was extremely insulting in
his letters
he used to call the pope stupid and
ignorant for not accepting his ideas so
the pope got a little personal and
decided to send his guards down there
and take him away so that was actually
the main reason it had nothing to do
with the fact that Galileo just randomly
said one day oh your theory is wrong and
then they killed him
um that that's actually very absurd and
very juvenile belief but in fact a lot
of atheists actually hold that position
they think that uh scientists were just
randomly persecuted because they had
different ideas which is actually
usually it's more political than that
so sorry go back one more time so okay
so implies Society rejected religious
Dogma in favor of scientific advancement
implies religion was an obstacle to
Scientific advancement we'll discuss
that more as well based on supposed
historical conflicts between science and
religion something I already discussed
just now in brief based on the beliefs
of what progressionism and scientism
okay so one more
hmm
the argument for secularism now this is
a very important argument
and uh it's probably
um one of the most important ones that
you're going to need to learn as well
and this one is directly affects you
okay and this is something that our
atheists argue actually predominantly in
society
anything that predominantly causes
violence sectarism should never be a
governing force is this correct anybody
agree with this
anything that causes sectarianism and
violence should never be a governing
work meaning shouldn't be in your
politics right you should not be
policing you it should not be governing
you okay
P2 religion predominantly causes
violence and sectarianism therefore
religion should never be a governing
Force
that's the basic argument okay
and this is the main thing that atheists
will talk about on and on and on and on
and on and on in their discussions even
before the existence of God comes into
the picture this is the main issue is
that religion is a drive for violence
and Division in society
okay now uh historical and observational
claim of the supposed predominance of
violence sectarianism religion implies
secularism is predominantly peaceful and
unifying
and based on the beliefs of humanism and
progressionism before you go on
I will be discussing this at length this
discussion that's this this particular
argument because this is very important
for us so I'm going to give you a brief
of what I actually believe in this on
this position here
the historical observational claim of
the supposed predominance of violence
and sectarianism religion is false
obviously I'm going to say that you
probably already knew right
but it's very false um the greatest
atheist argument I put a question mark
there because I want to save that for
later actually in part two and
um
this argument
is important
for many reasons one most atheists don't
know that they're making it
I know that sounds strange
they they subconsciously they make the
argument like this they have certain
beliefs that they form that they've had
from the previous beliefs that I
mentioned and they make a statement
which I will mention this argument later
on
and
um It's very effective because they shut
down all conversation this way this is
how they win the argument against people
who have religious belief
and um
the other reason it's very important is
because it is the central argument that
I'm going to be using
in my own arguments
to refute them
so I'm actually going to be utilizing
this very
argument that they use which I'll
display to you in part two okay to
refute them so I'm going to use their
own argument against them
and I've been working on this argument
for three years
yeah I know it sounds like ridiculous
like why would it take so long right so
because believe it or not when you have
when you're around a lot of other
philosophers you're constantly being
critiqued so you have to keep like
redoing it oh okay okay this could be
problematic so I'll change this word
okay no I understand where you're coming
from there I don't want to mess up so
maybe I'll
so you know you have to keep
reformatting until you get it just right
where it becomes uh annoying to people
and a philosopher knows that they have a
good argument when it annoys people
you know so that's I know it's it's
quite funny but
um so right as a as of the third year I
haven't had one objection to it
so I'm quite happy
I've showed it to other professors they
say it's valid some so I'm waiting for
somebody actually to give me something
substantial so that's why I like
teaching it to people now because I'm
waiting for somebody to tell me no
that's wrong because I want to see if I
can make it better you know but um so
far nothing
it's like a perfect Sudoku puzzle
so I hope that when I share it with you
it's not patent by the way
so you can use it you don't have to pay
me anything but when you use it
inshallah it'll be as effective for you
as it was for me
um I have counted the number of times
I've used it
and every conversation that I've used it
it's been probably almost 200 now I have
stopped the debate
and I've had a few people
not convert to Islam but they became
fused
as a result
so alhamdulillah
um it's hard it's much easier to
actually to get people to become theists
than Muslims
um you know I know
so
[Music]
okay I believe this is the end of uh
part one
okay
so thank you very much uh we're gonna
have a quick break for about 30 minutes
maybe if we can extend a little longer
because I think people want to eat
breakfast
and uh well I'll determine that with you
later and we'll get into section two
section two before we go to the break is
going to be about basically the history
of contemporary atheism I'm going to go
through some of the leading figures what
they believe and the progression of the
beliefs from a certain point in time I'm
going to discuss why there's actually a
rise in atheism
I'm going to give you the exact reasons
and I'm also going to discuss more about
scientism and I'm going to discuss this
argument as well at the end so please
enjoy your break
and thank you for listening to me
blabberlain okay thank you